hello patrons how's everybody doing you
know now that I am in Columbus I need to
organize a fan Meetup and what I think I
might do with this video is in like the
next month or two I think I'm gonna make
this one of the public kind of videos
that sort of real people in the patreon
its kind of said hey look here's the
kind of stuff that we do on patreon so
you may see this go live on YouTube in
like a month but again it's something
that I think we do like once a quarter I
think like four times a year maybe with
the vs. video so there's nothing too
terrible but in this video we are going
to be doing a battle royale of the
Batman fan you guys really seemed to
enjoy the Battle Royale of the Green
Lantern series and so I was like okay
let's see which one you guys want to do
mouths and you guys voted for a Batman
battle royale so this is the bat family
right and the winner of this battle
royale will take on none other than
Bruce Wayne himself and so beginning
with this whole thing and to start
things off it only makes sense to start
with Batman's oldest ally Dick Grayson
and I guess technically Alfred would be
Batman's oldest ally but we're limiting
this to only those who routinely see
combat I think that's pretty simple
pretty straightforward so Dick Grayson
has been around in comics for a long
time going all the way back to Detective
Comics number 38 in 1940 when writers
decided that kids reading comics needed
a younger character that they could
identify with and so when Dick Grayson
is introduced we learned that he comes
from a famous family of acrobats known
as the flying Grayson's now when some
criminal sabotages the trapeze wires in
the circus that they're performing in
Dick's parents tragically fall to their
deaths
now before dick can get to the police
he's approached by Batman and the two
bond over their shared history of
loosing their parents at a young age and
Batman ends up taking Dick Grayson under
his wing and makes him his ward and so
during this time Dick Grayson receives
extensive training and adopts a
superhero persona of Robin becoming the
first and most famous in a long line of
sidekicks to use that moniker now after
spending several years as Robin dick
decides that he's outgrown the role as
Batman sidekick and adopts the new code
name of Nightwing named after a
Kryptonian superhero that he met during
an adventure in the preserved Kryptonian
city of Kandor now adds Nightwing dick
served as the leader of the Teen Titans
as well as a solo hero and briefly took
up the mantle of Batman after Bruce
Wayne seemingly died during Final Crisis
now Nightwing possesses great acrobatic
skill due to his extensive training with
his family from a very very young age
he's also skilled in multiple forms of
martial arts due to his training with
Batman and Richard dragon and his
for the art of fighting with Kali Stix
in addition to his extreme proficiency
as a hand-to-hand combatant now in
addition to being at peak human levels
of strength endurance agility and
reflexes he's extremely intelligent and
in a DEP detective and is skilled in
stealth escapology and disguise now due
to his proficiency as a fighter and
detective Nightwing was a natural choice
to replace Bruce Wayne when it was
believed that Bruce had died at the end
of Final Crisis and so when dick became
Nightwing it left Batman without a
sidekick for a pretty lengthy period of
time and Batman editor Lin wine made the
decision to introduce a new sidekick to
fill the void which prompted writer
Jerry Dugan and artist Don Newton to
introduce Jason Todd in Batman number
357 in 1983
now Jason Todd was a troubled orphan who
Batman catches trying to steal the tires
from the Batmobile in Crime Alley of
Gotham City where Batman's parents were
essentially murdered now later after a
stent in a group home Jason assists
Batman in catching some criminals and
Batman brings him in as his next
sidekick fearing that Jason would become
a criminal if Batman didn't do this
Batman fans however were not fully
receptive of the new Robin so much so
that they famously with the help of
somebody who manipulated the whole phone
system voted for Jason to die in a fan
poll during DC's death of the family
event which ultimately led to his death
at the hands of the Joker in 1988 now
Jason would remain absent from comics
until 2005 when he reappears as a masked
vigilante named Red Hood who essentially
acts as an antagonist to Batman but
eventually the two reconcile and become
allies although Batman disapproves of
Jason's willingness to kill his enemies
and so Red Hood received the same
training as Nightwing although he is not
the same kind of natural athlete that
Dick Grayson was in addition to his
prowess in hand-to-hand combat Red Hood
is also an expert marksman and
incorporates an extensive cache of heavy
duty firearms and bladed weaponry into
his arsenal now after Jason's death
Batman obviously needed another Robin
and that's where Tim Drake comes in now
Tim Drake debuted in Batman number 436
in 1989 and was the son of a wealthy
family that demonstrates an extremely
high intellect at a very young age which
leads him to discover the secret
identities of Batman and Robin now to
finding out the Dick Grayson is Robin he
begins training himself
to eventually take up the mantle one day
and
the death of Jason Todd approaches
Batman and convinces him to make him his
new sidekick
now Tim eventually adopts the nickname
of Red Robin and goes from being
Batman's sidekick to more of an ally now
Tim's training is virtually identical to
his predecessors making him an adept
combatant but what really sets him apart
is his intelligence he is undoubtedly
the best detective of the Robins and
perhaps even more skilled than Batman
himself and is also skilled at computer
science and various other scientific
disciplines now to round out the Robins
we have Damian Wayne now Damian made his
debut in Batman number 655 in 2006 and
is the son of Bruce Wayne and Talia al
Ghul the daughter of Batman's longtime
enemy Ra's al Ghul that was basically
grown in an artificial womb and raised
in the League of Assassins where he
receives training to become you guessed
it an assassin now eventually Talia
informs Bruce that he has a son and
Damian takes up the mantle of Robin but
there's a near-constant budding of heads
between him and Batman due to Batman's
policy of not killing which of course
goes against everything that Damian
Wayne learned from the League of
Assassins
now Damian is probably the best among
the Robins in terms of fighting skill
having received training basically since
he was born
and has actually proven himself to be
more skilled than both Tim Drake and
Jason Todd when he's fighting them and
so while the Robin mantle is the most
recognizable and iconic of the Batman
allies the mantle of Batgirl has also
been an integral role filled by a
variety of characters the best-known of
these is of course Barbara Gordon the
daughter of Gotham Police Commissioner
Jim Gordon now Barbara Gordon first
appeared in Detective Comics number 359
and 1967 in an attempt to introduce a
female character that would increase
female viewership of the Batman
television show now when Barbara is
introduced she is attending a costume
party dressed as Batman and sees Bruce
Wayne get kidnapped by a super villain
named Killer Moth yes
Killer Moth was an actual name now
Barbara ends up stopping Killer Moth
which prompts Batman to forge an
alliance with her as the two of them
fight crime now Barbara remains in the
role of that role until she's shot and
paralyzed by the Joker
during The Killing Joke storyline of
1988 after that she's confined to a
wheelchair and adopts the new role of
Oracle using her expertise and
technology to aid her allies remotely
but when DC rolled out the new 52 in
2011
Barbara was rebooted to regain her
to walk and reprised her role is Batgirl
now Barbara is a skilled martial artist
for this is an extremely high intellect
and photographic memory and is a highly
skilled computer hacker now while
Barbara is the most widely recognized
Batgirl she's far from the only
individual to use that alter-ego
Helen Bertinelli the daughter of a
notorious crime family in Gotham City
first began operating as a vigilante
known as the Huntress after she was
framed for two murders and receives
training from richard dragon and the
question before returning to Gotham to
avenge the murder of her family now
hunters and Batman are often at odds
given his disapproval of her violent
methods in dealing with criminals and
after Helena briefly adopts the mantle
of Batgirl during the no man's land
story in 1999 she has a falling-out with
Batman and gives up the Batgirl cowl and
returns to her Huntress persona
primarily working with the birds of prey
and so Huntress is skilled in
hand-to-hand combat as well as with a
variety of weapons but historically has
used a crossbow as a primary weapon now
the next person to adopt the Batgirl
persona it's Cassandra Cain who first
appeared in Batman number 567 in 1999
now Cassandra's father David was a
bodyguard for Ra's al Ghul and her
mother is the famous assassin Lady Shiva
makuu Sandra was taught to be an
assassin from birth by her father but
was not taught how to read or write
instead focusing all her attention on
learning to read only the body language
of her enemies now after killing a man
and seeing the emotion on her face she
left her father and turns up in Gotham
City where she saves Jim Gordon's life
and becomes a new Batgirl under the
tutelage of Bruce Wayne now since the
new 52 went into effect cassandra has
gone by the alias orphan after the name
her father had previously used and it
doesn't seem she ever used the Batgirl
alias in this continuity instead
basically being taken in by Batman and
befriending Batman's allies Harper Row
and Stephanie brown now orphan is an
incredibly skilled fighter arguably the
most skilled of the bat family with the
possible exception of Damian Wayne
largely due to her ability to anticipate
the moves of her opponents as well as
for extremely high pain tolerance and so
finally we have Stephanie Brown who
first appeared in a Detective Comics at
number 647 in 1992 Stephanie is the
daughter of the supervillain cluemaster
who begins working as a vigilante by the
name spoiler because of our mission to
spoil her father's plants now when Tim
Drake temporarily steps away from his
role as Robin to try and live in
life Stephanie fills the void but it's
tortured and apparently killed by the
black mask now it's later revealed that
Stephanie's death was faked and that
after the apparent death of Bruce Wayne
Cassandra Cain gives her Batgirl costume
to Stephanie who adopts the mantle
giving her the distinction of being the
only person to serve as both Robin and
Batgirl now in the new 52 continuity
we've only ever seen Stephanie in her
original spoiler persona and Stephanie
is a skilled martial artist and
acrobatic and is set apart by her
expertise as a tracker and so in
addition to all the Robins and all the
bad girls there are a few other members
of the bat family that we need to go
over to get a definitive answer as to
who would win in this gigantic Battle
Royale
now the first of these is jean-paul
Valley also known as Azrael who first
appeared in Batman sort of Azrael number
one in 1992 now Jean Paul was part of
the sacred order of st. Dumas a secret
order of assassins who was brainwashed
into forgetting the fact that his father
had died and it was time for him to take
over for him
at which point his memory was restored
now he fights alongside Batman and
becomes an apprentice of sorts until
Batman is paralyzed by Bane and Azrael
takes the mantle in his place known as
Batman jean-paul Valley is far more
brutal than Bruce ever was because it
was the 1990s and everything had to be
super edgy and eventually bruce heals
from his injuries and retakes the Batman
cowl
now Azrael has seemingly superhuman
physical abilities including endurance
durability reflexes and agility Duda has
partially enhanced genetics having been
created in a test tube and his genes
having been spliced with animal DNA
now Azrael is also an expert fighter and
has bested Batman and combat and
utilizes armor and a flaming sword as
part of his arsenal now Katherine Kane
better known as Batwoman first appeared
in 52 number seven in 2006 now after
being kicked out of the US Military
Academy because of her sexuality she
descends into a destructive lifestyle
until she meets Batman after being
attacked and defeating a mugger
now this inspires her to begin her
career as a crime fighter and she steals
body armor and weapons from the military
base where her father worse than when
she trains with experts around the world
for two years she returns to Gotham and
adopts the persona of bat woman and
frequently serves as an ally of Batman
and mint for the younger members of the
bat family now that woman is an expert
gymnast and was an elite military
student that's received training in a
variety of combat styles as well as
strategy and survival techniques making
her an extremely formidable fighter in
her own right now moving on to Luke Fox
he's the son of longtime Wayne
Enterprises executive and innovator of
Batman's technology Lucius Fox now he
first appeared in Batman number 19 in
2013 and he takes over the batwing title
from David's of M'Baye a member of
Batman Incorporated who gave up that
mantle now like other members of the bat
family Luke is a skilled combatant and
also possesses a genius-level intellect
but primarily relies on his armored bat
suit and a variety of gadgets such as
retractable wings cloaking and healing
technology as well as bulletproof armor
and so finally we have the most recent
addition to the bat family Duke Thomas
also known as the signal now Duke first
appeared in Batman number 21 in 2014 and
were introduced to him as a young man
whose parents fall victim to the Joker
toxin during Batman in game now Duke
forms a group of teens that fight crime
in Gotham City all while wearing the
symbol of Batman's sidekick Robin and
has eventually brought in by Batman as a
sidekick now Duke differs from everyone
else on the list and that he's a
metahuman and possesses the ability to
look at the past or a few seconds into
the future as well as analyze his
opponent's weaknesses now he also has a
high level deductive reasoning having
trained his whole life to come up with a
riddle that couldn't be solved after the
Riddler calls a hurricane to hit Gotham
City and so now that we've gotten a
sense of what all these bat family
members can bring to the table the
question is how would this battle play
out so assuming that all these
characters are in a every man or every
woman scenario there are a few
characters that would be eliminated
fairly early on for one reason or
another for example when we consider
spoiler although she is an adept crime
fighter she really doesn't bring
anything to the table that isn't done
better by someone else she's not the
best fighter she doesn't have the most
impressive physical stats and even
though she is intelligent there are some
that possess higher intellect and so
when spoiler has to battle someone like
Nightwing or orphan she's going to be in
way over her head and then we have
characters who would be plagued by a
lack of experience
Duke Thomas is a metahuman but even with
his superhuman ability to look into the
future he's never displayed the fighting
prowess as some of the other combatants
and I see someone like Damian that's one
of the most skilled fighters in the DC
Universe and I think that Duke would
find himself completely outmatched
now on paper that wing would seem to be
a likely contender to win this battle
given the advanced tech suit that he
wears which would obviously give him a
physical advantage over his opponents
however when you have computer experts
like Tim Drake and Barbara Gordon in the
field either of them could find a way to
hack the computer running batwing suit
and some he just shut it off and so
without his suit battling would have to
rely on his physical combat skills which
is just are not on the same level as
others and so even with those three
eliminated we still have a lot of work
to do and narrowing down this field and
so for how this battle would play out I
think most of these characters will Duke
it out on the street and hand a hand or
close-range combat with a couple of
exceptions for example I think Tim Drake
is gonna rely on his strengths as a
computer expert to do most of us
fighting remotely through drones or some
sort of technology that would allow him
to monitor and attack his opponent from
afar with the goal of avoiding close
quarters combat which is his most
glaring weakness Red Hood on the other
hand full different strategy from most
of the bat family and that he
incorporates firearms into his arsenal
so he can literally sit up on a rooftop
somewhere and pick people off from afar
so that leaves Nightwing Damian Batgirl
bat woman orphan Ezreal and Huntress
duking it out on the street and that
melee is going to come down to fighting
skill and physical superiority no I want
to take this opportunity to point out
that for this battle I'm going to assume
that all these characters are going
all-out and they're not pulling any
punches because they're friends and so
that is going to neutralize hunters
advantage of being the most brutal so
she can really only capitalize on this
if the other characters are holding back
since they aren't I think her fighting
skill is not quite high enough as the
others here and she'll ultimately be
eliminated I also think that we can
eliminate Batgirl for the same reason
she's a great fighter but not on the
level of Damian or orphan and is nowhere
near as physically formidable is
Nightwing so I really can't see her
taking any of them out now probably the
most difficult of these characters to
place is gonna be Azrael the reason I
say that is that he's been written very
inconsistently in the pre and post new
52 continuities prior to the new 52
Azrael was capable of beating rusev Lane
in combat but he's been written as being
significantly weaker in the post
flashpoint continuity still he is made
formidable by the armor that he wears
that allows him to fly and the flaming
sword he carries that could be a
game-changer but in the current
continuity he relies on the suit of
Sorrows which houses an artificial
intelligence
allows him to identify the weaknesses of
his opponents now I think he would be a
strong contender to win this thing if it
weren't for the factor of Tim Drake
being able to potentially hack into or
disable that AI which could neutralize
his advantage to some extent but even
without his armor functioning at 100%
he's still an incredibly skilled fighter
and will be tough to defeat now as for
bat woman she's going to approach this
battle very strategically and that will
get her pretty far into this conflict
and she's going to strike at the most
opportune times instead of just doing it
randomly she's going to be able to hold
her own in combat with nearly anyone
around her and really at this point it's
going to become very difficult to parse
through who's going to win as each of
the combatants have many of the same
strengths in weaknesses Demian and
orphan have received extensive training
from the time that they were very young
so it can be tempting to say that they
will have the upper hand but we have to
keep in mind that both of them are still
exceedingly young and so in terms of
actual real world experience they still
trail behind the older characters not to
mention that they're not as physically
mature as Nightwing that woman our
Azrael so I can't really see them
emerging victorious because it really
just comes down to the fact that they
just can't kick or punch hard enough and
of those three I've seen Nightwing
being the last one standing and I really
can't see it going either way it just
seems it in the current continuity
Ezreal hasn't been shown to be the fight
of the night wing is as Nightwing is
usually compared to Batman in terms of
skill and for that reason I think he
could take down bat woman as well and so
essentially we have Tim Drake operating
remotely Jason Todd lurking in the
shadows trying to snipe people in
Nightwing who's been through the fight
of his life and probably exhausted and
the fact that Tim and Jason haven't even
had to mix it up yet I think it's going
to allow either of them probably Jason
to somebody just take out Nightwing from
afar even though Nightwing can in normal
circumstances avoid Jason shots but at
this point he's going to be too
physically spent and this will be his
undoing
and so who wins between Jason and Tim
well I think Red Hood would undoubtedly
win this if the two were made to trade
blows but I don't think Tim is going to
let it get to that point in my mind
Tim operates much like Batman and he
knows these guys he's fought alongside
and occasionally against them and so
he's going to have contingencies in
place for all of them and that might
seem like an anticlimactic
end to this but this is after all a
Batman story and Batman as we all know
can make up for any deficiencies he may
have
through preparation and intellect and
Tim operates in the exact same way
now if Tim does not had any prep time
and he's just thrown in the middle of
this melee then all this changes and
there's no way he wins and is probably
among the first to be defeated in fact
but if this were a comic book
I think we'd find out that Tim much like
Bruce would have essentially been
planning for this eventualities for a
very long time and so with that being
said if we were to take this one step
further and we picked him against Batman
what would happen well at this point in
Tim's life I don't think he's going to
be able to out Batman Batman if tim has
contingencies
Bruce has contingencies upon
contingencies in addition to that while
Batman may not actually be as advanced
in computer science as Tim is he is
undoubtedly going to have access to
technology that Tim doesn't since he has
pretty much unlimited money something
that Tim does not have now Bruce himself
has said that Tim will likely one day be
a better Batman than he is and while
that may be true that day is not today
and at this point no one's going to be
beating Batman at his own game but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end thank you all for
being patrons I really hope you guys
enjoyed this it's certainly the longest
of the vs. videos we've had so far but
it was really really cool I really love
doing this so make sure you guys keep an
eye out for the hole that we do in the
next day or two and yeah I will catch
you all later please okay I want to give
a shout out to Kyle B David Joseph then
john h aj matt in jeff our John H lean
and mean which is an awesome name Jason
see Austin s Austin a Joey M Steven Z
Austin B Adam K and Genesis 9 16 you
remember guys you can send me messages
and I'll run off whatever your message
is at the end of the video so long as
there's nothing crazy but if you want to
put a message in there send me an email
Rob at Robert Jefferson comm and if
you're one of these people who get shout
outs
then I will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch you guys
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]